chris fowler is going to be hosting
the heisman again tonight for the 27th
consecutive year chris will be hosting
and
showtime is at 7 eastern on the
mothership and then chris heads to miami
to call the national title game monday
at 8 eastern on espn chris joining us
from the
lovely confines of bristol connecticut
people have heard about bristol
connecticut
over the years over the decades chris
for those who have never been able to go
to bristol connecticut
could you give us a snapshot of bristol
connecticut
right now on a tuesday morning dan i
know much more about the campus on the
actual town of bristol because as you
know it sits right on the edge of
southington
right in the uh the dmz between those
two towns
so i uh i can tell you all about the
campus which i haven't been to in a
couple years by the way
my initial visit here so every time you
come there's a new building
it's very quiet very deserted very
spooky
but it's gleaming and beautiful and i
tell you they did a hell of a job i was
a little bit skeptical you take the
heisman out of that intimate setting
in new york and obviously it's a virtual
ceremony past winners will be on screens
as well the finalists
but they did a hell of a job dressing up
the studio which i think has the
fantasy league show normally in it
they've blocked that off and they've got
a beautiful looking room
uh for this kind of one-time only home
of the heisman can you give us uh
a look out the window there do you
really want to look at the view here
yeah i think just now this is is this
the radisson hotel or has it been
renamed it is now the doubletree
i asked for and they gave me a room with
a very special view
okay now that's the elevator testing
shaft yeah this is the this is where
this is the otis elevator building here
where they the tall building in the
middle of these hills where they run the
elevator up and down to test them we
have a construction i don't know what's
going on but they're building something
over here and
you can see the parking lot's rather
empty so that is your snapshot
thank you for the 06010 you asked for do
you remember your first day on campus
yeah absolutely i looked about 11. um
i was going to do a high school sports
show called scholastic sports america
i had been a fan of the network since it
signed on in in 79 so this is 86
when i arrived and they're like who is
this kid you know walking around in a
t-shirt
and you know i was like there was berman
there's lee there's tom knees these were
the early guys that
you know i stayed up and watched
sportscenter and i thought when they
called me to work here they were going
to put me on sports there said
we got something a special plan for you
you're going to hit the road
uh in coach and and you know
work 40 weeks during the school calendar
doing high school features but i love
that too
and i just i think the one i remember is
when you featured emmitt smith
yeah for some reason first football
player we profiled at pensacola escambia
yeah
and he became kind of like a lifelong
acquaintance it was very cool
all right so um the the game plan
tonight
um now when do you get the envelope
it's the same as the usual i don't want
to know ahead of time nobody on the show
knows who wins you just don't want to
have that but the commercial break
before
the announcement is made um i do get the
results then
because sometimes there's been a lot of
suspense and you just don't want to be
caught completely off guard
because in case the guy gives a short
speech i have to step in there for the
interview so you want to let
your eyes kind of look at the page and
see what's going on with the voting so
in that break before the announcement
i'm not on camera in that segment until
after
their name is read then i find out the
biggest question you
have tonight aside from who's going to
win
is is what well i have my stress ball
here i haven't needed it yet but
my biggest concern is we all do the
everything's on a screen like you and i
are right now
but you just want everything to be
buttoned up technically you know
all these guys you know for a minute
here my biggest concern
until i read something this morning was
that nick
saban's practice was gonna run into our
show because plan a nobody knows this
but plan a for alabama
was to have devante smith mack jones and
the rest of the tide
practicing for the championship game
right up until
about 6 central 7 eastern
when this show starts i'm thinking are
these guys gonna like are they gonna
have time to towel off
after practice are they gonna come in
sweat so they
you know devonte smith's a sharp dressed
dude he wears these tailored suits the
bow ties that's how he goes to the games
and i thought can you let the guy and
put a suit on and matt can
you let him at least dress up because
it's weird to be practicing for the
ultimate game
and have this potential life moment for
one of them be like minutes away but i
i was told this morning they moved
practice earlier i don't know what it
took to make that happen but
now these guys can chill i know they're
going to be there on time so that's that
was my biggest worry
is saban going to join you yes it'll be
part of the show
as will dan mullen and and uh and dabble
sweeney the coaches and the families you
know the two players whose seasons are
over
trevor lawrence and kyle trask it's a
very different deal
they can have their family there the
coaches it's going to be at their
team locations but it's a different vibe
than two guys who are still in the court
of sort of the alabama bubble
of getting ready for the game next
monday and you've been doing this such a
long time
we love to hand out that heisman in
september we love it
like beginning of october and
you know i i came in i forget how many
weeks ago and i said
devonta smith is the best player on any
football field that that he plays on
i don't know if he's going to win the
heisman but he to me is the difference
maker for that team
but you know i i it's when you start to
handicap this
what do voters see and what they what
should they be looking for
so let me ask you that what should you
look for
in a heisman candidate well
it's simple it says most outstanding
player on the ballot right but that's
open to interpretation for me i always
look at
what would the team be like if that guy
weren't there what would he what would
it mean if he was out
you know and i think we saw with
lawrence what it meant for clemson for
example
i don't know where florida would be
without kyle trouse but it wouldn't have
been in a new year six bowl game
battling bama for sec championship down
to the final couple possessions that's
for sure
and then the alabama guys you have to
judge you know there's the offense is so
good
i mean we're having this conversation
are they as good as lsu last year
which i think is the best college
offense i've ever seen i mean you smith
jones and harris and that offensive line
that
jones stays pretty clean in the pocket a
lot but you know you said something
about devonta smith i think it's
interesting dan and this year that's
been so different where the rules are
just basically tossed out
i think there is more momentum for
voters
to look beyond the usual quarterback
stats
and say them first of all damonte has
amazing stats as a receiver i mean
phenomenal stats
every good team they faced no matter
what they threw at him
he was off the charts and the better the
db he's across from
the more he embraced the challenge of
figuring out a way to beat that guy
and so i i think there's you've seen
lots of people endorse him
lots of guys have said you know demonte
smith is the best player
maybe this is a year to do that i don't
know if that's the way the voting is
going to go
but i think people would consider him a
slight favorite at this point because
there's been that late season momentum
you talked about
what is it 800 voters more than 900
900 voters yeah when are they voted now
people think they didn't vote after the
these bowl games okay they voted after
the conference championship games that
didn't change
so you can't factor in what you saw new
year's day and the other bowl games yeah
because if you did
then devontae smith your heisman trophy
winner right
well it certainly would have hurt the
case for lawrence and trask i'll say
that well the bama guys
just kept rolling i mean smith had three
more touchdowns against notre dame
that doesn't count in in the voting or
how we statistically evaluate but those
guys i don't think that heisman should
ever be given that
out after the playoff anyway you you
can't make it an award that's that's
tilted that much
toward the guys who had you know the
final word that to me is you'll never
have a guy win it off a non-playoff team
if you did that
he's chris fowler he'll uh be hosting
tonight for the 27th
straight year chris hosting the one-hour
telecast on espn the heisman trophy
ceremony it starts
at uh eight eastern well whenever
nick saban wants to start seven eastern
seven eastern
okay i got eight eastern here do you
well tune in is seven if you've got 207
okay let me change that
seven eastern national title game eight
eastern
yes okay or whenever saban wants to show
up for tonight's
tonight's ceremony as you we move
forward hopefully we get back to
whatever normal is
calling a game you know herme called you
know last week from home
does the pandemic as we move forward out
of it does it change
broadcasting in you know games you know
on site i hope not i mean i enjoyed
being on site for a lot of years and
there's an experience that's special
a lot of the stuff that is fun about the
job i'm the last one to whine believe me
but the contact with the coaches and
players in person hasn't been there you
don't get to watch
practices everything is a screen
everything is reading
in the booth you know everything is a
screen you can't have a spotter near you
can't have a stats guy near you
that's all the code protocols everything
is a source right you just look at all
these screens like your
air traffic control you miss a lot of
the human contact our crew can't meet
you know in a room everything is a zoom
meeting and
i miss i miss that contact a lot i mean
i don't like the idea
of having to call play by play off a tv
screen
we're going to be doing that the
australian open because of all the
complications of going to melbourne at
this point we're going to be doing
oh well tennis off the tv i know a lot
of guys have done great work a lot of my
colleagues
have not been uh able to go on the road
and call games so these they call these
games
remy games i don't know why they're
called remy but that that means where
they
everybody's kind of virtually there's
there's teams that done football games
this college football season
the guys have not met each other
playback play and
analysts have never met yet they're
calling games from their respective
homes like kirk and it is our 25th
season together
so it helps when he's in nashville i'm
in the booth
to have that kind of oh my god chemistry
that built up over a quarter century
i was wondering in um the the hit on
justin fields
like what kind of information can you
get
uh would it have been different if if
everybody was in person and they
you know that because i don't know if
there was ever a medical update on
justin fields
with that hit oh you mean what what's
what he might have sustained
yeah we were told that they they got the
the x-ray room ready at halftime
so you're thinking oh they're gonna go
look at his ribs
but it wasn't for him he didn't get
x-rayed and he admitted after the game
he took a couple of injections or at
least an
injection which you need to get through
the pain because you saw how he was
grimacing there when he got hit in i
thought i thought oh my god
that's broken ribs or maybe they'd have
checked for a kidney injury yeah
and you know they're not saying what the
injury is i mean
justin didn't attend the interview
sessions that we had set up
and that the cfp had set up yesterday
maria taylor was supposed to talk to him
he didn't make that appointment so
obviously that sort of raises concerns i
mean ryan dave says he expects him to
play
i would certainly hope so but you know
there's going to be a certain amount of
cloak and dagger before the championship
game and they're not getting down there
until
maybe the day before so you're not going
to have eyes on many practices
if any uh to check that out but you know
god he's got play
he just has to play is herbie going to
be on site with you
yes that's the plan hey dan this is hour
to hour brother
i know yes but he will have cleared
protocol he is going to be on site i
don't want to do a championship game i
hope i'm on site man i got
i probably got i don't know what like
two three more tests i gotta pass forth
before i get the booth
i've had 54 this year if you're counting
54 kovats are you 54 no
i am undefeated undefeated i'm not doing
all humility
i'm not i'm not doing the victory dance
i'm not spiking the ball don't be
taunting i i i don't i don't want to
you know flag you for uh you know
taunting it's the announcer jinx you
just you just gave it to
me uh while i have you the uh steve
sarkeesian situation here
uh how does that affect alabama in the
national title game but
what do you think of the hire for texas
well i i think stark will handle his
business calling plays any better he has
to
you you couldn't take him out of the
equation i was talking to smith and
jones as part of my prep and you know
they were
they were relieved that he was going to
stay on and call the plays you cannot
disrupt that engine at this moment i
mean guys have done it before but
he's the play caller he's a huge part of
that and you know
him him matching wits with ohio state's
defense is a big part of the game
texas is a really hard job you got to be
a politician i've talked to mac brown
who was you know the most successful
coach there post
darrell royal and you have to navigate
your way through some very murky choppy
waters everybody in texas who's
the trustee down there gives a bunch of
money they all want to be jerry jones jr
and they want to have a say in the
program there's a lot of stuff to deal
with
but beyond coaching football and i i
hope stark
um can manage all that stuff because man
he can he can call plays
and he's a good recruiter and and i'm
happy to see him you know he's had he's
had
two sort of like redemption trips back
to tuscaloosa
with saban and i think he's i i feel uh
i like him a lot and i feel for what
he's had to go through off the field
and i hope that part of his life is
conquered forever and i hope he has
great success in austin
he's uh chris fowler tonight at seven
eastern
the uh heisman trophy ceremony and then
eight eastern on monday night the
national title game who did you vote for
by the way
oh okay okay mike i'm 27-0
for once they're not in the same room
but i'm you know
you can't you can't say who you voted
for and then go out there and host the
show come on but good try
okay i mean i think i'm uh oh and 20
years before
yeah i voted okay but i'm not allowed to
tell you oh yeah that's right nobody's
supposed to tell actually right you're
sworn to secrets here they could
they could come and take your ballot
away right well they did ask
you know because i do you know tell
people on the show because i said you
know hey i watch a lot of football i
take this
it's a great honor to vote and uh you
know that you
i i almost got into a fight this a
heisman fight with craig sager
years ago in miami outside the
clevelander hotel
okay so we both have beers in our hands
and uh i said to seger
how disappointed i was in the heisman
voting
because a freshman should be able to win
adrian peterson to me
i thought deserved the heisman trophy
okay
so three minutes later we're we're
nose-to-nose
we're gonna fight over adrian peterson
uh should he win the heisman trophy
paulie
had to jump in true story
sega and i were gonna throw down over
adrian peterson
i'm just i'm just picturing you and
sager probably had a plaid sport coat on
uh with beers at the corner of tenth and
ocean ready to throw down on the heisman
brothers just
yeah i i i think it's what what color
would
uh was that salmon fuchsia he had a
fuchsia colored
jacket on he's a big guy can you imagine
police showing up
what's uh what's the argument about
adrian peterson
oh as you were go ahead you guys can
throw down i've seen plenty of
beer-fueled fights at that exact
location
many years at cleveland here my friends
used to own that place and that that was
a
that was a hangout but that's a great
memory you get a visual picture you give
me thank you for that dad
uh have fun tonight as always chris we
appreciate your time and good luck on
monday night as well thank you sir
appreciate it that's uh chris fowler
seven eastern heisman trophy tonight
he'll be awarding that
and then monday the national title game
starts at 80 stream